it's Wednesday the middle of the week
and Jess and I have dusted off our best
cardigans to celebrate we have but we've
also got a bunch of news for you so
let's get straight into that if you
liked destiny won then you're gonna love
destiny too at least that's what it
sounds like Bungie is saying in a recent
interview you probably remember the
criticism surrounding Destiny's
less-than-stellar story but now Bungie
you've come out to explain why that was
and what we can expect from the sequel
cinematic lead Matthew Ward explained
destiny won in a way was foundational it
was meant to set up the world and ask a
lot of questions but not necessarily
deliver too many answers but leave
enough out there for us to build upon
Ward added that Bungie you're working
from lessons learned through the
development of destiny 1 he also said I
hope people complain about how much
story we have that would be the reddit
thread I'd like to read too much damn
story makes angry typing gesture sting
your narrative lead Jason Harris added
the Bungie spent a lot of time well
building for the franchise and players
can expect to see story infused
throughout the game like every other
game yeah pretty much like that
Destiny's beta it kicks off on July 18
for those who pre-ordered and July 21
for everybody else so go see for
yourself
you better start pinching those pennies
5 cent pieces and rupees because it
sounds like the PS 5 might be launching
in 2019 at least according to an analyst
Wedbush Securities analyst Michael
Pachter told gaming both that he expects
the next PlayStation to launch in 2019
and be another half step similar to the
ps4 Pro he explained to thinking saying
Sony is probably timing it better
because they're going to bring out a 4k
capable device when the 4k TV market
reaches 50% in the USA and 35% in the
rest of the world Pachter went on to
speculate that the PS 5 will surely
support 4k and that it will play games
built for the ps4 Pro what do you think
of the idea of iterative console
generations for me personally I like the
idea of more frequent console
generations that are backwards
compatible with the majority of my
existing games but do let me know how
you feel down below in the comments
you'd better start working on your
Zenyatta skills Dan because Wizards have
officially announced a bunch of details
for the overwatch league as rumored New
England Patriots owner Robert Kraft will
own the Boston based overwatch Lee
team there will be a total of seven
teams based around the world with Jeff
Wilpon owner of the New York Mets owning
the New York team LA's team will be
owned by immortals eSports team Miami
Orlando by misfits gaming San Francisco
by NRG esports shanghai by Nettie's and
soul by kevin chu co-owner of Kabam the
announcement makes the overwatch league
the first major international pro
esports league with a traditional sport
style city based structure there's still
a ways to gather by comparison Major
League Baseball has 30 teams with things
to expect closer to expand the roster of
teams in good time
overwatch league commissioner Nate Nance
at old games but we don't have a set
number in our mind right now we want to
grow this over time the overwatch league
was announced at Blizzcon last year and
will kick off later this year at a venue
in the LA area with home and away
matches in the league's future if you're
interested in the full details you can
head on over to GameSpot and make sure
you subscribe so you don't miss any of
the details on this one that is
everything we've got for you today
thanks so much for joining us and
remember we'll have more news for you
same time summer
[Music]